[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and now Diana wave and
stop for housing
[Music]
it's the 30 year anniversary of full
house and with the third season of its
sequel series fuller house heating
Netflix this Friday now is the time to
countdown its best episodes this series
lasted eight seasons from 1987 to 1995
and for a time aired on ABC's iconic
TGIF block Full House was very popular
among those who followed the show and
while it was never a critical hit it was
always a very high rated program after
it ended in the mid-90s and began
running on syndication it became even
more popular and is still airing across
TV to this day the syndicated run has
created new fans and now multiple
generations have grown up with the
Tanners and that familiar San Francisco
home what are the most memorable and
best Full House episodes though there
are quite a few considering 192
installments aired so let's find out
right now these are the top five best
episodes of full house
[Applause]
number five another opening another
no-show from season seven Uncle Jesse is
reopening the long closed down smash
Club and even landed the band REM well
sort of however as time ticks down to
letting the first guests in everything
that can go wrong does Jessie gets
locked in a storage closet with Kimmy
Gibbler and has to find a way out to
salvage the club's Reed a beaut this is
one of those episodes that never left me
I probably saw it when it first aired
and many times since then
Jessie being locked in the storage
closet with Kimmy as his new smash Club
opens without him is just very memorable
to me as is this line the smush Club
since Jessie and Kimmy are stuck with
each other we also get a rare moment of
tolerance from the annoying neighbor and
the hair obsessed uncle you really hurt
my feelings
[Music]
like the REM joke also worked pretty
well when they break out into whippet I
still chuckle a bit Ben Stein with a
ponytail also has a guest spot in this
episode and it's great because it's Ben
Stein with a ponytail
excellent
Jesse making his unintentionally
spectacular entrance on the disco ball
is also a memorable moment him reopening
and owning the smash Club was a logical
step for the character and brought back
a repurposed set for future episodes
number four road to Tokyo from season
six Jesse's cover of the Beach Boys song
forever may have only hit number 99 in
the US but soars to number one in Japan
Jessie Becky and their Twins head to the
Land of the Rising Sun for a short tour
in front of his adoring fans while this
is a dream come true for everyone's
favorite uncle Becky soon starts to see
the fame go to his head as Jesse begins
to forget what matters most to him this
was a really good premise from the
beginning the fact that Jesse finally
gets to live out his dream of being a
huge rock star
but it's in a foreign country is ripe
with comedic potential for an episode
personally I think they could have made
this a really fun two-parter with some
on location shooting in Tokyo but for
what it is it's still a top 5 worthy
installment Jesse's Ark in Japan is
pretty by the numbers but it's nice and
effective after seeing her husband start
to lose touch with what's truly
important to him Becky calls him out and
a pretty well acted scene as full house
goes just agreed to tour for a whole
year without so much as asking me what I
thought well have fun just like we've
been having oh yeah just it's been a
blast eating without you sightseeing
without you kissing the kids goodnight
without you the real star of this
episode is of course Koji break out the
good stuff honey-roasted I love this guy
you're talking to your fruit
it's a small part but I loved this guy's
great real jerk okay
you're a jerk right big you jerk you're
right
major sure once Jesse returns home we
get a nice little scene with him and
Michelle and it wraps up one of the
show's best episodes number three
silence is not golden from season six
when Stephanie finds out a classmate of
hers is being abused by his father the
boy Charles makes her swear not to tell
anyone about the domestic issue
Stephanie begrudgingly agrees but when
Charles is missing from school the
following day due to a suppose it fall
down the stairs she breaks down to her
Uncle Jesse about her dilemma
this is definitely an episode aimed at
getting a message out to kids but it's a
good message and I think it was actually
done well here rarely do things get this
serious in the show for such a serious
reason and I think that's why this one
stands out my dad's gonna kill me
you can't tell anyone as long as you
live okay
okay Stephanie is one of if not my
favorite character so I like that this
episode focuses on her and how she
handles this situation her conversation
with Uncle Jesse about this problem is
also handled well I know you want to
keep your promise but if you know this
is happening and you don't say anything
about it you're only helping it happen
again but what will happen to Charles if
we report it what will happen to Charles
if we don't well that story line takes
up the bulk of the episode there are a
few lighter moments hold it not so fast
hey you know what entity that was a guy
I really like this story a little arc
for Stephanie she ends up appreciating
her father more and realizing just how
lucky she actually is also topanga's in
this episode so extra points for that
number two
Michelle rides again part two from
season eight the series finale and
conclusion following part one
Michelle rides again sees the effects of
the youngest Tanner's injury from
falling off a horse she has amnesia and
can't remember who she is or any of her
family members the Tanners tried to
remind Michelle of all they've been
through as she struggles to get her
memory back as a full house series
finale I was satisfied with this episode
part one isn't bad but really just a
setup
they recap it at the beginning then get
into the more interesting stuff I'll
admit it was a bit heartbreaking seeing
this for the first time way back when as
a kid of nearly the same age
Michelle was my point-of-view character
and definitely a charismatic scene
stealer seeing her act so different and
not remember anyone was emotionally
effective when I was younger obviously
less so now but this was a pretty solid
way to create some tension as the series
wrapped up there's a point where
Michelle asked where her mother is and
you can just see the mood in the room
change the tragedy at the center a full
house is seldom directly mentioned after
the first season but when it was brought
up it usually made for a good scene
I'm sorry but your mom died when you
were just a little girl
mary-kate nationally Olsen also share a
scene as Michelle and her memory when it
returns to her at the end of the episode
it's my job I'm remembering where the
heck have you been I've been looking all
night
Steve surprise return was appreciated as
he was absent for the entire final
season the last scene has the whole
family together in the living room and
was a nice send-off but stuck it out and
I got through just like we always do
just like we always will
this was the last we saw of the full
house universe until it was revived in
the new Netflix series just last year so
I had a lot of honorable mentions for
this show but I'll just list the ones
here that came closest to making the cut
chances are if you loved an episode
that's not here I probably loved it too
but here are the honorable mentions that
almost made the top 5
[Music]
and the number one best full house
episode is the wedding parts 1 & 2 from
season 4 Becky and Jesse are getting
married
but when Becky's father has a talk with
his future son-in-law about giving up
some of his dreams for a family jesse
panics and decided to jump out of a
plane as the final adventure of his
Bachelor life when he gets stuck in a
tree on his way to the ground
he becomes late to the wedding and
everyone becomes frantic trying to find
him so he can marry the love of his life
Becky and Jesse were dating on the show
for a couple seasons by the time this
finally came around they almost got
married in lake tahoe in season 2 but
that's a whole other story
this was built up for a while and it
wouldn't be full house without something
going wrong so Jesse's conversation with
Becky's dad is the catalyst for the
chaos it could be a husband with a wife
responsibilities commitments he's pretty
heavy isn't it yeah it's heavier Jesse
and joy going up in the plane led to at
least one funny line
oh my god he'd jump without his mos
after Jessie is late to the church
everyone begins to wonder where he is
this is where the two-parter gets good
as we get some rare on location scenes
that involve Jesse trying to make his
way to the wedding
eventually Becky finds Jesse in jail but
when she gets him out her car is being
towed
thus they come up with a unique solution
aren't you and wake up San Francisco yes
I am I'm Rebecca Donaldson and this is
my fiance Jesse Katsopolis all right
thank you we really appreciate this
this leads them all back to the church
where the wedding takes place and we
hear a certain song for the first time
on the show
[Applause]
[Music]
I think this is Full House at its best
while always cheesy this episode is
humorous and heartfelt it's probably the
Tanners at their happiest and we get a
nice little adventure thrown in in my
opinion this one stands above the rest
[Music]
was it always well-written no but full
house knew what it was as a wholesome
family sitcom with characters that
people like I'm not embarrassed to say
that I still enjoy watching it when I
see it on it's like a warm blanket or a
hot soup on a cold day so thanks for the
memories full house I'll be watching and
most likely reviewing season 3 a fuller
house as soon as I get the chance I want
to hear what you guys think what is your
favorite full house episode what do you
want me to cover next on the show leave
a comment and let me know for more
content subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter like my
new Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome Walter B and follow along on
Twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week for one more full house
top 5
[Music]
you